or go online to c-span org slash shop
and click on book TV next on history on
book TV diamonds a journey to the heart
of an obsession
Matthieu hearts new book explores the
history of the jewel and the lives of
those who work in its high-stakes
industry the program runs just over an
hour
thank you for coming I am happy to
welcome Matthew Hart to the Tattered
Cover he is here to introduce his new
book diamond a journey to the heart of
an obsession mr. Hart is a journalist
who has reported from all over the world
for the Canadian media and since
becoming a freelancer in 1981 has been
published in The Atlantic Monthly
Reader's Digest Travel & leisure history
numerous TV document documentaries plus
two IMAX films and published three
novels and two other works of nonfiction
including golden giant the story of the
greatest gold discovery in the Americas
and hello Ontario in addition to all
these accomplishments he is a
correspondent for the New York monthly
wrap-up or a diamond report and the
magazine's former mining editor as you
can see he has certainly qualified to
write about one of the most sought-after
glamorous gemstones in the world
diamonds the story ranges from the
sublime to the sinister as he covers the
modern history of the diamond trade from
the discovery in 1859 of diamonds in
South Africa and the riches that that
discovery brought to Cecil Rhodes and
Ernest Oppenheimer the debate De Beers
cartel controlled the trade the recent
discoveries that have eroded that
control and the so-called war diamonds
that have contributed
- so much misery and corruption in
Africa today this fabulous stone has
found a worthy biographer and mr. Hart
as he certainly has captured the romance
and adventure of the diamond trade
please join me in welcoming Matthew Hart
thank you very much hi
well diamonds have been in of course in
the in the news again I was watching
from my hotel room in San Francisco the
some of the build-up to the Academy
Awards and the I could I saw these news
clips with the a spokeswoman for the
diamond information center in New York
talking about all the diamonds that had
been lent to the the various actresses
because not one diamond that you saw up
there is actually owned by the person
wearing it they're all lent by jewelers
but this information is all coordinated
and and generally it's it's how much
they're worth because that's what people
want to know buy the diamond information
center which sounds like some kind of
government body but it's it's a division
of J Walter Thompson the big advertising
agency and their work is 100% funded by
De Beers consolidated mines surprise
surprise
that's the the government of diamonds
really it is you could call it a
government agency because De Beers is
the government of Diamonds and I like
big diamonds because they they they
attract people there's the the flash of
big diamonds says a lot about the
business I remember a couple of years
ago when Whoopi Goldberg
Goldberg was again cheering she had a
106 carat stone as she kept saying this
is a hundred and six carats a hundred
and six carats and flashing it before
the cameras and I know the guy who cut
that stone in New York Louis Glick and I
was talking to him after about it and I
said you got a lot of good publicity
about that stone and he said yes but you
got the wait wrong it was a hundred and
five point for a hundred and five point
four and he was incensed
anyone would misrepresent the weight of
the stone and then of course the value
is given as 18 million dollars it's been
18 million dollars stone but you know
who knows when you get up to a stone
there's something's worth 18 million
dollars it's not like a like a car or
something but they just put a price on
it
it's very notional what it's worth if
you can find somebody like the Sultan of
Brunei to buy it
that's probably what it's worth but I'd
like to talk a little bit about I had a
very nice review of my book not long ago
in the Washington Post and one of the
things the reviewer said was that heart
seems to have a certain fascination with
the dark side of the diamond business
and I thought well yes heart does
because that's the biggest side of the
diamond business the dark side and
diamonds have been prey to people for
thousands of years when the when the
mogul Conqueror babbler swept into India
in 1526 and defeated the armies of the
vastly superior armies of the Sultan of
Delhi at the Battle of Panipat the first
thing he did after stealing his victory
was to rush to the agra fort and seize
the great treasure of diamonds that lay
there and among those diamonds were some
of the diamonds that remain the most
famous in the world today the 13 carat
pink known as the agra pink the great
diamond known as the Kohinoor Kohinoor
means mountain of light it was well over
200 carats at the time and Babar seized
it almost really is a symbol of his his
rule so I think these this was kind of
the beginning of a jewelry regalia where
the jewelry was not on not only
symbolized power but was part of the
manifestation of the power of the ruler
and then a couple of hundred years later
when the when the British
took over India conquered India well
they took the Kohinoor to in fact you
could say it was an act of theft because
when they seized the Kohinoor diamond it
was as part of the treaty it was a
clause in the Treaty of Lahore that gave
them when they when they annexed the
Punjab it was part of the Treaty of
Lahore that gave them the Kohinoor
diamond and the monarch forced to sign
the treaty of Lahore was only six years
old the Maharaja of Lahore a minor do
lips sing now the Cohen er was then
presented by the East India Company
which had got hold of it to Queen
Victoria and it was the job of the
governor-general of India Lord Dalhousie
to get it back and we know from his
correspondence that he found that a very
onerous job because basically of course
paraphrasing but in one of the letters I
remember do one of his friends he said I
was never so glad to put anything on the
boat in my life as this diamond when it
got back to London crowds flocked to see
the diamond such was its fame they there
was an exhibition in Hyde Park and it
was mobbed by people they were a little
disappointed in the lack of brilliance
in the diamond and the Prince Consort
Prince Albert took it upon himself to
organise the polishing of the diamond
they hired a a Dutch cutter who had a
new steam-driven cutting machine well
skate just a diamond wheel that that's
how diamonds are mostly mostly cut and
polished by grinding because with a
wheel that's impregnated with diamond
because only diamonds will wear down a
diamond and it was this this thing was
assembled at Gerard the crown jewelers
it was a very very big deal the Duke of
Wellington men in an advanced years rode
up on his charger two guards on the day
it was to be cut
he fastened the stone the Kohinoor into
the dock and brought it down onto the
wheel no doubt with a lot of instruction
and one of the reporters for The Times
asked one of the gerard brothers what he
would do if any damage came to the
Kohinoor while it was in their hands and
while they were entrusted with polishing
it and he said I would take my nameplate
off the door and bolt and at any rate I
was I was I caught a little news item
just last year about the Cohen R because
and it was I forget exactly where it
appeared but it was a demand by the
Taliban who were still in power to the
to Queen Elizabeth to return the Cohen R
and I read this and I thought return the
Cohen er but surely it was not a you
know they never had the Cohen or theirs
I got a nice sort of leaf through
everything quickly all my sources to see
where the what the Kohinoor is great
rude had been because the various
conquer seized it and sure enough for
one brief period it was it was held by
somebody who was sort of like transiting
Afghanistan I lived there for about
thirty years
so in its thousand-year history and the
Kohinoor stayed in Afghanistan for
awhile so they were demanding its return
but I have no that's how I called the
British to see what was what was going
to happen whether this would ever get to
court and I ended up speaking to a man
who was the keeper of the Queen's
something or other but not jewels but
some kind of precious objects and he
said it hasn't been brought to my notice
so I guess they have no real intention
of sending the Cohen er vac it sits in
the Tower of London in a crown that was
made in 1937 for Queen Elizabeth the
Queen Mother and it's a it's an amazing
stone there are many larger diamonds but
few can be are as famous but I think to
have one other story I just like to say
about so I think of that is in some ways
a stolen diamond
but there's another diamond that was
stolen it was the most famous diamond
probably in Europe at the time and this
was a large blue diamond known as the
French blue it had come into France in
1668 in a baggage of Giambattista Vernay
who was a great traveler and gem trader
and he took it to the only person he
thought could really afford the price he
had in mind and that was louis xiv and
of course the Sun King bought it
immediately so we're told in 1669 he
bought it this was in December of 1668
the tavern you brought it in Louis we
know had it by early 1669 so that's
buying it pretty quickly
he had it for a couple of years and then
he sent it to be polished by his
goldsmith Patel who the diamond was some
two hundred carats in PTL polished it
down using the very primitive tools
available then to about 77 carats or so
I'm sorry there abouts I I could be
corrected but the right figures in there
and it's sort of a heart shape a blue
diamond and this became the most
cherished diamond of the French Court it
was known as the Blue Diamond of the
crown but much more familiarly known as
the French blue lui wore it at his
throat Louis the sixth though his
successor Louis the 15th his queen wore
it in her hat they were always having it
reset in some order that they would wear
in in a prominent position it was by all
accounts the most gorgeous beautiful
rare and amazingly beguiling diamond in
all of Europe at the time of the French
Revolution when louis xvi tried to flee
with his Queen Marie Antoinette and they
were seized and brought back to Paris
under guard and imprisoned in the
Tuileries
order broke down in a French state at
least or in Paris civil order declined
rapidly there were riots and there was a
storming of the Tuileries and the
Revolutionary Government which now of
course owned the crown jewels or at
least was their custodian decided that
they weren't safe at Versailles where
they were under guard and brought them
all into Paris and the French blue and
all the other many many diamonds of the
French Court and louis xiv had coats
sewn with diamonds shoe buckles made of
diamonds buttons made of diamonds he
must really have looked like the son
they brought these jewels into the gaud
midler which is was a building it's
still there actually but it's on the
present day + la concorde and over a
period of one week robbers broke into
the gardener blend looted many of the
jewels and among those taken was the
French blue the French blue disappeared
for some years and in fact it's only
really in the last 10 or 15 years that
scholars have figured out what happened
to it and if you want to know what
happened to it all you have to do no no
I'm not gonna say by the book I'd never
do that I'm not that heartless is go to
the Smithsonian Institution in
Washington DC and there you'll see a 45
carat diamond called the Hope Diamond
that's what happened to the French blue
it was polished down it was taken to
London smuggled to London and London had
as its greatest source of diamonds in
those days India Brazil and the French
Revolution and they they polished three
diamonds out of the French blue and this
is the largest and you can see it in the
Smithsonian so when you look at it you
must realize that it's a stolen diamond
but I became very interested in the
modern-day criminality because the
diamond world is rife with
and of course it's not all kings and
queens there aren't very many of those
anymore and the diamonds are very very
well-guarded now they're all in the
Tower of London the ones that belong to
the British royal family anyway and the
French crown jewels are in the Louvre so
they're hard to get at but diamond mines
are robbed quite a bit and I went up
from Cape Town once to a little town on
the diamond coast of South Africa which
is in the northwest corner of the
country up against Namibia the sea and
the coast from about a hundred miles
below the Namibian border which is the
Orange River up to at least a hundred
miles into Namibia is very diamond rich
the beach is rich in diamond and so is
the sea and mining ships mine the seabed
and miners harvest the diamonds from the
beach under as close scrutiny as the
miners can provide port north is a dirty
dusty unlovely little place mostly
wrapped in fog and yet at the north end
of it there's a quite a large collection
of very very prosperous looking villas
each one with a good collection of
northern European cars like Mercedes and
subs and big you know lots of fancy cars
and no visible means of support that's
really what you'd say about Port
knowlet's a lot of people seem to have
money and yet oh no real business there
for them to get the money from and what
they do is they they are really
launderers and diamond smugglers there
are two mines in the area one is the
South African controlled mine
that's on the South African side of the
Orange River and the other one is the
biggest prize in the diamond Cleef's
Universe and that's the mine on Anna
nippy ins side the richest diamond beach
in the world and for many many years the
richest diamond ground in the world the
diamonds were deposited on the beach
millions and millions of years ago
eroded down from their original volcanic
source inland
and washed out to sea and they remain
there they they on the beach they strip
away the overburden with these huge
machines that look like big Ferris
wheels and then they get right down on
the bedrock because that's where the
diamonds will be on the former bedrock
this warmer seabed and they they're
caught in crevices some of them quite
large and the miners used to mine these
by sweeping them up a little whisks but
that was too easy for them to steal
because they were actually there getting
their hands right on them so De Beers
introduced these huge vacuum cleaners
called trans VAX and they get down there
and Hoover up the diamonds nonetheless
they do find ways to steal them notably
by corrupting the security which is
probably pretty thoroughly corrupt well
we know that it is and also just by
flicking a diamond up their sleeve when
nobody's looking
or by stamping their boot hard down on
on a piece of rough diamond at you that
they see and the the main security for
the mine would lie in preventing these
miners from getting the diamonds out of
the secured area of the mine and they
have of course x-rays because diamonds
fluoresce under x-ray so how to get the
diamonds once you've stolen them out of
the mine and what they did well here's
what happened they were always
encouraging the miners to come up with
activities because mostly they're single
men who just sit around inside this
diamond mine all day brooding about how
to steal the diamonds so they were Kurt
tried sports and this sort of thing and
one of the representatives of the miners
approached De Beers with the idea that
the miners be allowed to keep homing
pigeons so yeah right away you'd think
they'd say what I don't know this does
sound very good but they thought that
was a great idea because homing pigeons
are very popular in that part of the
world as a sort of sport there's a lot
of pigeon fanciers and they thought this
will keep the guys busy well what they
did they run a virtual burst of stolen
diamonds inside their their hostels
which cannot be rated for reasons of
political sensitivity that they won't
get into but there's no there a lot of
diamonds they man
to loot the beach very very easily and
they would what they would do is get
their pigeons and trust them up and put
them in their lunchboxes and then all
this has to be put through the x-ray
before you go out to the diamond beach
but it just looks like a piece of cold
chicken because they used to bring those
out in their lunch boxes so they the
guards would just assume that they were
bringing their food out in the lunch
boxes they get out to the beach and they
had these little leather sacks really
little little sandal bags if you want to
call them that made which they were then
fastened to the well we're already
fastened to the pigeons feet and then
they just load these up with ruff and
off goes the bird and of course it's
just another bird taking off and flying
on over and of course the bird then
being a homing pigeon goes home and the
home is not in the mine it's somewhere
off the mine this was the thing that one
would have thought the viewers would
have thought we don't know how long the
homing pigeon thing went on because of
course no one knows exactly how much
they're being robbed in the diamond
business I mean not a not from a mine
because of course you don't see what's
being taken however we know how it ended
because one day a security of one of the
zoo one of the security staff saw a
pigeon that was just too loaded to get
off the ground
the guy had stuffed probably about ten
carats of Ruffing and the thing just
couldn't get up or not wouldn't a bit
more than that because the pigeon could
easily lift that much ruff it must have
been it must have been more than that
maybe even a hundred carats anyway there
was this thing beating its way along in
the dirt
thrashing its wings against the ground
and it couldn't get up and that was the
end of the pigeon scheme so that's next
scheme that they brought into the
diamond beach or that particular mined
Namdev was the crossbows game and this
they managed to smuggle in the pieces of
a crossbow or perhaps they only brought
in wood they wouldn't have shown
anything in the x-ray and the other
metal components were made in the
machine shop by their
friends the same way that they would get
diamonds off the beach sometimes by
dropping them in gas tanks and they go
to the machine shop and somebody cleans
them out well that they're all working
together not always just out of avarice
because they're quite well-paid for
people in that region many times out of
coercion because organised criminal
syndicates operate all of the diamonds
leaving in southern Africa and I mean
Botswana Namibia and South Africa in
Angola it's a different story that's
where the diamond wars are but anyway
they would they they so they managed to
build a crossbow or several of them and
they hollowed out the arrows filled them
up with diamonds and at night they would
get out from the you know far away from
the hostels close to the perimeter
fences was safe and fire the arrows over
the fence at some I guess preordained
area and they'd be picked up later and
that went on until one of the arrows hit
a security Jeep and then the crossbow
deal ended so these there's just some of
the ways that the mines were robbed more
often in the bigger mechanized mines
what they do is they were where the
whole object is to keep people away from
the diamonds that's the whole object in
diamond mining don't let anybody touch a
diamond for God's sake because they'll
steal it the so in the big mechanized
recovery plants diamonds are recovered
basically by being mined up out of the
ground out of these big pits and the the
or gets sort of just washed and broken
down and the big rocks thrown away
sometimes they throw away big diamonds
in them too and they get found later but
the then it all goes into a sort of
slurry and diamonds have a specific
gravity of three so this slurry is has a
specific gravity of less than three so
all the lighter material then will float
off and just the heavy gravel and the
diamonds will sing
to the bottom then this gravel with
diamonds in it
is fed onto a conveyor belt and the gist
is the conveyors coming on it's very
nice it feeds about five strains of
gravel on and it goes quite quickly and
just as it's sort of everything that
starts to fall off the edge of the
conveyor belt the it's bombarded with
x-rays and as you know diamonds
fluoresce under x-ray and if there's a
photomultiplier mounted to detect this
bursts of fluorescence and it triggers a
little jet of air that just goes and you
can hear it although you can't see it
because they always have this enclosed
and it knocks the diamond out of the
stream and it goes into a box with a
little bit of other gravel and then they
sort it with glove boxes you know
there's a glove inside you stick your
hand in from the outside and that's how
the diamonds are supposed to be sorted
sometimes they put little slits in the
end of the glove so they can press down
on a diamond and get it out that way but
mostly what they do in a diamond plant
is somebody will drop a monkey wrench
into the machinery when nobody's looking
wreck it then that means they have to
come and fix it so once they come and
fix it the screens are all removed and
now they're in among the goods so that's
how people try to engineer it same with
the diamond chips they engineer a break
down so that they can they can get to
the goods so all right perhaps i should
also talk about what brought me into the
writing about diamonds I became
interested because of a discovery in
Canada I had already written a book
about gold mining and had many friends
in the mining business or contacts in
the mining business and particularly in
that sort of stock promoting end of the
mining business or they get these little
companies going the companies that keep
prospectors in the field and I like them
because writers find such people
attractive since they lie a lot so
there's deceit then there's also large
sums of money so a lot of money to see
it's good it's fun to write about and
when I heard about this big diamond
discovery in the Northwest Territories
300 kilometers northeast of the
territorial capital of Yellowknife I
thought what any sane man would think
baloney they're at it again
so I thought this is a stock promotional
skein of some kind but I didn't realize
that in fact there are many good reasons
why there should be diamonds there and
people have known about it for years
had been looking for a long long time
and in fact De Beers had been looking
for more than 40 years
it's very diamond perspective country
diamonds like a nice thick ancient slab
of rock to come up through they're
formed in seas that lie to depth of
about a hundred kilometers I beg your
pardon a hundred miles much deeper and
this is called the these seas are called
collectively the diamond stability field
and that's where there's just the right
conditions of heat and pressure to form
carbon into diamond they're harvested
from this great depth in the upper
mantle by a certain type of small
volcano that erupts beneath the these
seas of rock or kind of rock called
peridotite rich in diamond and passes up
through them carrying gathering into the
rising column of magma diamonds and
diamond bearing rock and taking it up to
the surface most of the time the
conditions it encounters on the way will
be hostile to the survival of the
diamonds and they will flee from the
diamond state into some other Carbon
state such as graphite which is why
these volcanoes when we go looking for
them extinct volcanoes which are called
pipes kimberlite pipes because of the
rock named after the town in south
africa where this rock was first
identified Kimberley most the time they
have no diamonds because they've been
destroyed on the ride to the top but
this ancient type of material which
overlies most of Canada and a great deal
of Russia and in fact southern Africa is
this sort of provides a relatively cool
environment for the pipe to rise through
and if it rises fairly swiftly at just
the right speed the diamonds survived
however what led people to these
discoveries was another mineral a garnet
because the geologists have come to
understand that there's a whole array of
minerals that are cousins of diamonds in
that geologists understand their
relationship to diamonds and they are
formed with diamonds and one of these
and and more importantly they exist an
order of magnitude more populous than
diamonds there are many many many more
of these minerals and one of them is a
garnet called a G 10 garnet which is a
very high purple garnet because it is a
high chrome content very beautiful when
you find gravel rich in these garnets I
wish you'd call me now if you you you'll
see it gets its red it's just red and
the garnets are extremely they're just
completely bewitching and they learned
that these these that you could look for
these diamond indicator minerals and
they would lead you to a diamond pipe
what happened was the search got
underway in the United States in the
late 70s in fact it got underway in
Colorado they were started to explore a
pipe called the Sloane pipe and then
there were various other there various
other diamond occurrences here but not
not really economic and then a one of
the people who'd been hired as that one
of the geologists who'd been hired as a
sampler asked if he could take the this
this knowledge and and and start looking
for diamonds in Canada and they started
to find kimberlite pipes right away but
nothing with any diamonds in them the
wrong kinds of garnets and certainly no
diamonds
they carried on with their exploration
and one year they were in northern
British Columbia on a large kimberlite
pipe called the mountain di'ja train and
one of these one of the partners in this
exploration was flying out and he asked
the bush pilot flying them and anything
going on around here just the way they
gossip up north and this guy said no
there's really nothing there's just this
company called mana Pross that are
camped on that Mackenzie River and this
guy knew that mono cross was De Beers it
was a wholly owned subsidiary of De
Beers and so he knew they were looking
for diamonds because what else would
they be looking for so that night they
flew over in helicopter and sampled the
streams upstream of where the De Beers
can play and they found all kinds of
garnets
however they believed that the garnets
didn't come from the area that they had
been transported there by Glaser that
they came instead from far to the east
from somewhere in that territory known
as the Barrens part of the Northwest
Territories it's called the Barrens for
obvious reasons it's above the treeline
there's nothing there
it's a huge prairie of polished granite
and lakes and gravel that's been
dribbled out by the glaciers this began
an 8-year search they found indicator
minerals Shoals of them trains of them
right away
red red gravel big milky jade green
chrome diopside x' and other diamond
indicator lovely lustrous ilmenite they
found all the right things and here's
what they thought they should be able to
do the glacier has taken the this
material and moved it down here and I've
found it so if I walk back up in the
direction the glacier came from I ought
to find where the glacier got this
material and that'll be the pipe because
that's the way it's supposed to work
the direction of the Glacia glaze show
flow is called down ice and when you go
back trying to track up the direction it
came from it's called up ice they
tracked up ice for eight years and could
never find the source one day Chuck 51
of the geologists was over flying his
area of exploration and he spotted one
of these little lakes and noticed the
for the first time how very round it was
now the surface expression of a
kimberlite pipe is round
really the pipes are like a big carrot
they're round and they taper down like a
carrot and he looked at this and he
thought man you know that looks just
like a pipe and then he thought that is
a pipe he thought about it they landed
he found huge masses of Dimond indicator
minerals on the down ice side of the
lake
and he thought that's it this is what
happened kimberlites a very soft rock
the glaciers moved across the land and
gouged out the top of the kimberlite
pipes and then smeared the indicators
down ice and then when the glaciers
melted back the depression which they
had themselves gouged out of the top of
the pipe filled with meltwater so they
couldn't find the pipes because they
were under Lakes they were all under
legs so that winter they brought a drill
onto the ice poked a hole in it and they
pulled up 81 diamonds so that's how the
discovery was made and my favorite
Discoverer up there was a 24 year old
woman and I wrote a chapter about her in
the book IRA Thomas she was 24 years old
really the the inks still wet on her
geology degree and she because there was
at this time height and diamond
exploration up there she ended up being
the chief geologist of her father's
company
at a time when they had a joint venture
with a very very big company that had
many many targets to explore up there
because of course there was a huge
diamond rush as soon as there was this
discovery ass taking rush they ended up
staking mineral claims roughly the area
of France from Coronation Gulf to Great
Slave Lake it's just huge and so there
was all this exploration going on and
IRA believed she had discovered a
cluster of pipes beneath a huge lake
like DeGraw and she had the drill out
there and in the spring the ice the
spring came on very quickly that year
and the ice started to melt she was
certain that there was because of
indicators she'd found on shore and just
her her magnetic surveys and her gut
instinct that there was something there
but they had many targets to drill and
Rio Tinto the very large English company
that was their senior partner had a
strict rule one hole in a target and if
it doesn't come if it's not a kimberlite
of you don't hit something right away
you have to move on to the next target
because they're very very expensive to
drill everything has to be flown in by
helicopters well IRA drilled and did
nothing but wrecked the drill on
boulders and overburden that lay at the
bottom of the lake pulled it up tried a
second hold anyway even though she
shouldn't have still couldn't find
anything by now the ice was starting to
melt and the crew wanted to pull the
drill off the ice it got to be very
dangerous even flying out there because
there was a lot of fog around the edge
because there was now open water around
the shore so they had to come out by
helicopter and there'd be fog around it
sometimes one of the drill crews had to
work two shifts in a row because they
couldn't even bring out a relief crew
because there was fog and little wind
would come up blow the fog away they'll
and the crew
she kept drilling and one day I guess
the crew had she managed to get them to
promise to drill one more time one more
hole by this time the drill Shack was
awash in water the whole surface of the
lake was covered in water
the ice was still under it of course
very mushy and the drill Shack had been
propped
upon these ties like railroad ties they
put another hole down bent the casing
pulled it up stuck a new casing on put
the hole down and bingo and next year
the mind that they are now building on
that site will start producing what will
be 6 million carats a year of very good
white diamonds so impressive was their
discovery that eventually Tiffany became
the largest single shareholder of that
company and they're gonna handpick the
goods I guess and so that just Express
I've I've picked these two areas because
I think they explain part of my own
fascination with diamonds I think that
and it's a very interesting business I'm
not a diamond collector obviously I
leave that to the Sultan of Brunei who
has a very large collection and his
younger brother who was getting a very
large collection until the Sultan took
away his credit card because he bought a
20 million dollar pink in New York and I
think that was the end of his collection
but it's it's the very very many
interesting characters particularly
fascinating since diamonds are 100%
useless you can't make clothes out of
them you couldn't eat them you can't
drive them home at night after the party
they're good for nothing except what
they do to light and what they do to
light is of course incomparable but
that's what you have to want so I'm
happy to take any questions you have
like I've had a long day
so our diamonds like great works of art
each diamond intrinsically has some
special special quality no matter how it
is polished or is that the polishing
which brings it to its ultimate glory
well diamonds come do they have
qualities individually these stones err
well yes they certainly do particularly
the large famous stones because and
that's why they're so valuable because
they're rare some are very pink and the
Hope Diamond is a very very dark inky
inky smoky you know I've heard it
described so anyways but a very dark
blue and E and you can get lost in the
thing I heard a great story about the
Hope Diamond I got into correspondents
email corresponds with John White who
was a former curator of minerals at the
Smithsonian we were arguing about the
misreported weights of the hope the
hopes been reported at forty four point
five and forty five point five and
there's all kinds of literature and we
were both comparing notes and he was
also arguing with me about various other
things but we've straightened it out
were the fastest of friends now but he
told me this story they decided to weigh
the hope at the Smithsonian to get the
to make sure to finally establish
without a doubt exactly what the weight
was so they took it out of its setting
and they were just going to weigh it in
the in the lab downstairs and somebody
dropped it now diamonds are the hardest
substance known to man
but they can break because that's how
they cleaved them and it was well known
that the Hope was very very stressed in
its interior it has all kinds of
interior stresses so you can just
imagine a sort of ah how would you like
to be the guy you wrecked the Hope
Diamond like you'd be looking for
another job I think pretty quick anyway
so he's sure there's a lot of them but
the and diamonds all present a different
polisher to a different rather challenge
to the polisher because each diamond has
its own problems that have to be
polished around but I hope that answers
your question
yeah mr. Dickens between Jim
free-falling diamonds and just your
industrial quality diamonds and where
they're found no no there's no
difference whatever all mines produce a
full range of goods some are cursed with
having many many more industrials than
they would like to have such as the
Argyle mine in Australia which also has
so it has the the crummiest diamonds in
the world and also some of the best
because they have pink diamonds there
their diamonds are so brown they tried
to create a new category of diamond
marking they tried to create these
cognac you heard of them and champagne
but I don't think anybody's really
bought that yet like they're just not
white is what they are you can call them
what you like you can call them
Sauternes they're just not white
diamonds the Pink's sell very well but
industrial uses are not filled with any
natural diamonds anymore
they're filled totally 100% with
synthetic goods because they can be made
to specs and mine and and one of the
biggest manufacturers of General
Electric in Worthington OHIO they make
and De Beers makes a lot of synthetic
diamonds too the reason main reason
DeBeers makes them is they want to know
how people do it because they don't want
anybody ever to be able to make a fake
that they can't detect however there are
some pretty good ones and and enhanced
color diamonds that I'm not sure they
really can detect there's a firm in New
York Lazar Kaplan International which
has a joint venture with General
Electric and they take a certain class
of diamond that's off color and they
take it to the synthetic diamond presses
and they basically bake it for another
like you know give it another million
years worth of heat and pressure and a
diamond color improves on this certain
class of diamond the diamond color
improves apparently forever though
they've only been on the market for a
few years forever we'll have to wait a
while but I don't think they could tell
those diamonds the GI a in New York the
G Gemological Institute of America
diamond lab in New York grading lab says
they can tell but you know what they
don't say how they can tell and I don't
think they can
so yes there could be diamonds on the
moon
well there certainly could be because
certainly oh there are diamonds on other
planets the diamonds as a commodity as
an as a material predate the Sun they're
older than the earth and older than the
Sun and in fact diamonds that we now
find on earth today could be what we
know from having observed in nineteen
get when it was recently the whole
astronomers observing a supernova by
spectrography Spectre whatever a
spectrograph right take out that right
detected diamond because of course the
the signature the spectrographic
signature of diamond is different from
other there's another carbon
thanks they detected diamond and they
they and we also know that meteorites
hitting the earth are sometimes three
hundred times richer in diamond material
than a diamond mine on earth that this
micro diamond content like they're
twenty tiny diamonds but they're there
there's more diamond matter in there so
Steven Haggerty at the University of
Massachusetts has done a great deal of
work on this and and it seems very
likely that when the earth was in a
molten State for a period of about four
hundred years it was subjected to a
reign of diamond like material and that
space is full of all kinds of diamond
material and so since we know that
crystals grow by adding layers to
themselves it's quite possible that some
of the diamonds we mined today and maybe
even a diamond one of you has on her
finger right now has it it's very Center
a little dot of diamond more than ten
billion years old
in other words older than the Sun it's
quite possible I'm not I don't know that
they're ever I I don't know of any way
that could ever be proven but it nor can
it be disproven and Pluto or Neptune
I'm sorry I can't remember which one but
there was an experiment some students
devised that at I think Cal Tech and
they detected diamondden on one of those
planets and and posited a rain of
diamonds into the planet so yeah I think
that the trend toward mapping and
branding diamonds is gonna have any
significant effect on the you know the
underground traffic and diamonds
give me specifically blood diamonds
diamonds from African Wars not just that
you know how Tiffany's and Lazar you
know they they map and brand diamonds
and Gi a maps the diamonds for the rapid
team alpha oh you mean you mean to give
a diagram of the dad do you think that's
gonna have any effect don't know that
what will you just it just as a diagram
of the diamond within a description of
it all that is a certificate saying how
what quality the diamond is yeah no none
of none of that will affect what is
known in the diamond trade is ID be
illicit diamond blame all the because
they'll always be a buyer for diamonds
since they're anonymous
they're just cash that has to be
polished to be realized there's no
serial numbers and it's moved through
all kinds of places probably a lot of
the angolan blood diamonds which some of
you may have read about that fund wars
in Africa and notably the biggest one
longest-running one being Angola a civil
war for more than a quarter century
those diamonds probably flow up largely
through Russia which has a very big
diamond industry already in place very
active very professional and also an
extremely large criminal class very
active and then of course Antwerp and
Tel Aviv and Bombay are sitting there
and they'll buy anything like show up
with diamonds nobody's gonna be saying
how can I be sure those are clean
diamonds all they want to is the price I
mean this is the reason that the United
States is so wants to know so much about
al Qaeda and we could bring these
stories about Osama bin Laden possibly
being in the illicit diamond business
and I don't know why he wouldn't be
because it would be the perfect cash and
it brings together several things he
needs it untraceable money diamonds
untraceable a criminal group to support
him Russians the Russian mob and the
largest source of nuclear material which
apparently he's interested in Russia so
I think it probably makes sense but I'm
not saying they're not very pretty
stones and most of them are mined quite
legitimately the Blood Diamond trade
accounts for quite a small it's shameful
completely shameful and the diamond
trade could snuff it out in a minute
no problem all it would take it'd be
tough legislation in the United States
which is the biggest consumer by far of
diamonds but nonetheless most diamonds
are just mined by people who work 9:00
to 5:00 and you know go home to their
kids no no I crave big ones but I I
don't have the money I don't have the
money to buy one and I don't have the
noise to steal one
so my diamond collection is limited to a
couple of very small diamonds from India
that weigh four points four points the
point is 1/100 of a carat so these way
for one hundredths of a carat they're
perfectly polished into a 58 faceting
cut but you need a little stronger than
these to get a really good look at them
but uh I'm enchanted with the diamond
business and with Diamond people in the
diamond story I don't have a wish to own
a diamond ring for myself and
fortunately no one I know is asking me
for a for a for a diamond but I've got
the four pointers there try popping the
question with a four point diamond here
you go huh what's salt
I was a little frosted at the national
Geographics cover because they noticed
they said the real diamond story well
they sent that story to me and draft to
read to check it over and they had some
queries which I very generously I
thought and answered and then it comes
out the real diamond story that what how
dare they but I haven't read it actually
just the parts they sent me to read and
check in draft hundred thousand people
doing what in India Oh in India the
number of diamond story I didn't hear
the question the number of done and Paul
Scholes polishers in India varies
according to the demand for the product
and how the business is doing but it
could be anywhere from six hundred
thousand to well one diamond India trade
diamond diamante
Gerald Rothschild of the Rothschild
banking family in London told me that he
thought it was as many as a million
polishers and they yeah they're they're
amazing they add value to these tiny
tiny stones and that's why there aren't
as many throwaway goods in a diamond
mine anymore that sort of low-level
stuff if it's big enough to be polished
it's a gemstone diamond it doesn't
matter how crappy it is they'll put it
into pardon me they'll put it how
unattractive it is they'll put it into a
jewelry they'll use it to brighten
jewelry so
that in diamonds go from value
well they're manipulated a little bit
DeBeers controlled the operator to
cartel for more than a century which
controlled more than 80% of the world's
supply of rough diamonds uncut diamonds
rough and when the diamond supply
softened because of a fall in demand
they choke back the Diamonds supply to
the market and that meant that the price
would then go up that started with Cecil
Rhodes as soon as he seized control of
the diamond mines in Kimberley in 1881
or 18 late 1880s I guess he immediately
cut production by 40% immediately and
the diamond price shut up overnight in
London so now the there hasn't been a
steady growth in the diamond price but
it's mostly trended up every now and
then it slops around a little and there
was some weakening last year but I hear
now that the diamond sights which is
what they call the London sales De Beers
sales done is ten times a year in sight
in London they're the most important
diamond sales that they're up to half a
billion dollars worth of rough each time
10 times a year so so it indicates a
fairly strong strong market so they just
you know they grow the demand and I
guess they buy advertising and people
seem to want diamonds and the markets
expand their markets in in Asia now that
weren't there before
but the biggest market the United States
by far now if Tiffany
bye-bye solve the diamonds from this
discovery in Canada so they bypass two
beers that's right and that's good for
them it's wonderful because it helps to
break up the old cartel well it's
wonderful and not wonderful there's two
ways at this but it's what it is it's
Tiffany's the greatest retailer in the
land in the world
a diamond retailer and they have
bypassed the cartel now they did never
buy directly from the cartel anyway
because they're a retailer so they had
to buy from polishers who bought from
the cartel so but now Tiffany what it
gets is 50 million dollars a year worth
of diamonds from the share that IRA
Thomas is the company IRA Thomas was
working for it gets now they have a 40%
share in that mine so out of that 40%
share Tiffany gets first crack at the
goods because Tiffany only sells top top
goods absolutely white high white
flawless very very expensive top so
they'll pick them out yeah it'll be I
don't think they'll be any saving to the
consumer at all that that's for starters
no I mean Tiffany isn't gonna say we're
gonna pass on to you and Tiffany isn't a
polisher anyway so they still have to
have the diamonds polished but it's very
interesting and what it does do is if
the blood diamond issue ever becomes
there ever really threatens the diamond
business which so far it hasn't
there hasn't been any fallen consumer
demand in the United States because of
all the publicity about the diamond
worse and conflict diamonds but if it
ever does if it ever comes up again and
threatens the Tiffany has a line
directly into conflict free diamonds
untainted diamonds diamonds from you
know fresh-faced apple-cheeked Canada
however not slow freshman I was assured
by some pals of mine up there they said
we are not I said how much how much
rough do you figure you're losing now
and they said no no no we're done we
don't have we have we're losing zero
ruff and I said well I'll take that as
being 5% because that's as low as you
could ever keep it they know that there
are already actually organized
motorcycle getting organized biker gangs
very big organized crime in Canada it's
it's one of our big problems and the
RCMP knows that there's already a lot of
biker gang activity in Yellowknife and
probably some of them may be working in
the mine and also Russian visitors that
we don't usually have up in Yellowknife
so there is no doubt that there'll be
those mines will will be leaking a
little bit as as we say and it's not
it's too bad because it's money that
goes into the criminal world and the
criminal it makes the criminal world
stronger and then their ability to
coerce other people maybe people who
aren't as well able to who aren't well
able to take care of themselves I think
of maybe some of the well they tend to
get into sort of tribal situations where
there's strong family ties knowing that
if they corrupt somebody the likelihood
of this person ever being turned in by
somebody else in the group is very slim
that's what why they're trying to what
they're trying to in Botswana now the
South African syndicates are getting
into Botswana in a big way and De Beers
has built this huge new plant called
aquarium that's that's nicknamed
aquarium and the aquarium stands for the
because of the acronym fish which is
fully integrated sort house meaning and
and another one another recovery another
acronym but basically what it is is a
recovery
the very latest technology that promises
to keep the plant people even further
away from diamonds than they were before
so that anyway that's the diamond world
I'm sure I've made it sound very dark
but there are wonderful people in it
including great cutters and people who
are quite heroic really in their lives
the United States could eliminate the
blood diamonds in a minute Wow
all we'd have to do would be to set up a
commission saying you can't well first
of all this is there they're doing some
of this saying will you have to have a
license from us to import and and in
order for you to get that license we
have to have the ability to spot audit
your polishing factory any time we like
we can arrive and you have to show the
proof of where your diamonds came from
and and there are ways of constructing
an audit trail so that that would be
hard to to fool and also there are
scientific methods of detection one
being worked on by a professor at
Caltech by the name of George rossman
who was part of a group that Clinton put
together to study the whole issue and he
came up with this this this means of
examine of of measure or excuse me
somehow or other it relies upon the fact
that the the ice that isotopes of water
is that right to say isotope of water
that isotopes of water are different in
every part of the world and even when a
diamond is mined and washed and acid as
rough is cleaned in acid Rothman's work
found that a tiny bit of soil adhered to
the surface of the diamond from wherever
that diamond had come from and he could
get water enough water
vaporized enough water out of that
it in unimaginably small amount of soil
to get the isotope reading and then he
just had to go to his map and say well
there this diamond came from their
Angola
so if that happens and you're caught
with one of these diamonds in your
stream all they say is okay
you can't export polished goods to the
United States anymore and that would be
the end of the death of that guy's
business there just isn't doesn't seem
to be a great deal of it's not high on
the political right it's just in all the
you know that in the battle for
priorities it doesn't have a big
priority was that Tony Hall Ohio
congressman whose most active in it but
there you go alright it thank you thanks
very much good idea well thank you I
hope so I'll try oh sorry yeah the most
recent diamond type created that's been
found is you mean when it was how old it
is yes yes actually the the the type
that the Academy n-- is coming out of in
the Northwest Territories is 47 million
years old which makes it quite young and
they dated that because it has bits of
wood in it that are not petrified wood
even in fact I have a piece you could
light it so I'm told I'm not going to
because I treasure it and actually it's
from the work in that pipe and and BHP
the the company that's doing the mining
they have a huge big they've chunks of
it up at the mine site and from this
they know that there was a dense forest
of Sequoia covering that part of the so
paleo botanists get in on the on in the
act too it's it's it's wonderful these
these pipes bring up this material from
the mantle and and anyway preserve other
material that I guess they
actually burn Emperor hits a soft sand
what if I'd arrest this Wow thank you
so if anyone wants to buy a book I'll be
happy to sign it Matthew Hart is a
correspondent for the New York trade
magazine Rapoport Dimond report and the
magazine's former mining editor diamond
a journey to the heart of an obsession
is published by Walker & Company visit
Walker books comm for more information